a convoy of trucks loaded with food and
other basic Goods reach Nigeria's
capital near me
the much-needed supplies arrived under
armed escort
but the relief they bring will only be
temporary so the country's borders with
echoa's member states remain close and
attacked by armed groups have been
increasing
at Miami's main Market abdulk other
wonders when and why his next supply of
grains will come now that the border
with Nigeria is shot
we want to bring in good but it's
impossible to do that from what's left
in the market isn't enough to go around
on a normal day this provision store in
central near me would be busy now the
traffic has slowed down to a trickle
prices of food and other supplies used
to be cheap here now they've gone beyond
the reach of many
I came to buy pasta milk and rice only
to find out prices have risen between 20
to 100 percent
buyers blame traders who in turn pass
the cost onto the consumer
you can't go and buy supplies at
exorbitant rates and resell at a loss
the major dealers are the ones
responsible
many buyers and sellers here blame the
regional block Echoes for the difficult
situation people are passing through
on the Nigeria Nigeria border hundreds
of trucks still wait for a chance to
cross an opportunity they're hoping for
since the coup more than three weeks ago
with a defined military leadership in
yemi an echo is not shifting its
position the situation is unlikely to
change soon
economic and financial sanctions by the
regional block led to cash and energy
shortages Nigeria the main electricity
supplier to Nigeria turned the switches
off on its neighbor leading to job
losses as businesses can produce medical
supplies and other Essentials are also
running low
knows that as long as there are
international sanctions that could erode
its support base in Miami where
thousands of people still turn up in
solidarity and to condemn echoes Ahmed
Idris Al Jazeera Abuja